This dodecahedral cage is made of silica
and it's tiny, really tiny.
It was created by researchers in the States
who hope that one day it could
help in the fight against cancer.
To give you a sense of just how
small this nanocage is
let's start with a single grain of salt,
it's around 300 microns wide.
Compare that to say a red
blood cell, that's it there.
Now compare the red blood
cell to something much
smaller like this the HIV virus.
The silica nanocage is a bit more
than ten times smaller than that.
To make it researchers use
a relatively simple technique.
First they need a template. For
that they use soap molecules.
When in solution the soap molecules
form tiny balls called micelles.
The size of the micelles is precisely
controlled by the researchers.
Then they add a silica precursor to the mix.
Gradually the negatively charged
silica precursors are
attracted to the positively
charged micelle template.
Over time they build up forming the structure.
The template could
then be washed or burned out
which would leave a
perfect dodecahedral cage.
What's more this process happens without any intervention,
it's self assembling.
This is how the researchers
think that the cages form
but until recently they
didn't even know they existed.
They're so small it's nearly impossible
to snap a picture of them.
To get that glimpse of the nanocages
researchers used cryo-electron microscopy.
They put their sample on a tiny disc
and plunge it into liquid nitrogen
flash freezing it.
Then they can use an electron
microscope to take a peak,
making images that look a bit like this.
They repeated the process over and over
to gather nearly 20,000 images of
the fuzzy looking cages,
all lying in slightly different positions at
different angles and orientations.
Now here's the clever bit. A computer
can analyze and average out all the
different images of all the different
orientations of the structure.
So feed them into a computer and an algorithm
can reconstruct a 3D representation.
And what popped out was a perfect
dodecahedron, only 11 nanometers across.
Studies have shown that ultra-small
silica particles can easily and safely
pass through the body being excreted in
the urine, rather than getting stuck in
the liver which can cause side effects.
Perhaps nanocages like these
could be used as containers
for things like
anti-cancer drugs
or as ultra small vehicles to carry diagnostic molecules.
But that is still a long way off.